[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء التقى الرئيسان
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي والفلسطيني
محمود عباس في القاهره يوم الاربعاء وذلك
بعد اربعه ايام فقط من لقاء جمع
بالقيادي المفصول من حركه فتح محمد دحلان
وبحث معه الوضع في غزه حسب ما ذكر قيادي
مقرب من دحلان نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش
في محورين ما هي الدلالات التي يمكن
استنتاجها من لقاء السيسي بعباس وخصمه
دحلان خلال اربعه ايام فقط وما حدود الدور
المصري في الملف الفلسطيني وتاثيرات الوضع
الاقليمي على الخلافات الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
حسب تصريحات لسفيان ابو زيده وهو احد
القيادات الفتحاويه المحسوبه على دحلان
فان الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي بحث
مع القيادي المفصول من حركه فتح محمد
دحلان في القاهره عده قضايا من بينها
الوضع في غزه ومعبر رفح اربعه ايام بعد
ذلك التقى السيسي بالرئيس الفلسطيني محمود
عباس بحث معه قضايا من بينها ذات
الموضوعات التي بحثها مع
دحلان الرئيس السيسي اكد على اهميه الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي يستقبل رئيس
السلطه الفلسطينيه محمود عباس بعد ايام
قليله من لقاء السيسي بمحمد دحلان الغريم
السياسي لعباس رسميا قيل ان الرئيسين بحث
مساعي انهاء الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من خلال
مشروع قرار في مجلس الامن وقبول عضويه
فلسطين في محكمه الجنايات الدول
وبشان المحادثات مع دحلان تسرب انه تلقى
وعدا من السيسي باحداث تطورات ايجابيه في
معبر رفع تبدا هذه الايام الخلافات
المعلنه بين عباس ودحلان المفصول من
اللجنه المركزيه لحركه فتح تطرح اكثر من
علامه استفهام بشان من تخاطب القاهره قد
يخدم السياق الاقليمي الراهن رئيس جهاز
الامن الوقائي السابق في غزه والمستشار
الامنيه حاليا في دوله الامارات اكثر من
اي وقت مضى هل حان وقت عوده او اعاده
دحلان الى الواجهه السياسيه الفلسطينيه
بدعم اكثر من طرف اقليمي استفاده البعض من
خبرته الامنيه في محاربه الجماعات المسلحه
لن يكون بدون مقابل دحلان لم يفقد يوما
الامل ولم يدخر جهدا من اجل محاوله العوده
الى اللجنه المركزيه لحركه فتح لا ينتهي
طموحه هنا فمن خلال اللجنه يمكنه الوصول
الى كرسي رئاسه السلطه في رام الله وهو لا
يزال يعتبر اتهامه بفساد واختيال شخصيات
فلسطينيه مجرد تصفيه حسابات سياسيه يحمل
دحلان الرئيس عباس فشل مفاوضات السلام
والتسويه مع الاسرائيليين والوضع
الاقتصادي الصعب في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وتحديدا غزه المحاصره هل سيكون الدعم
الاقليمي والدولي احيانا لدحلان كافيا
لتجميل صورته لدى كثير من الفلسطينيين
وجعله المرشح الا لخلافه عباس قد يكون ذلك
غير كاف الان ولكن لا شك ان الرجل وزوجته
التي تنشط في العمل الاغاثي لا يضيعان
الوقت في سبيل جعل المستحيل
ممكنا موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
رام الله محمد الحوراني عضو المجلس
الاستشاري لحركه فتح ومن غزه صلاح ابو
ختله القيادي في حركه فتح ومن القاهره عبر
الهاتف اشرف ابو الهول نائب رئيس تحرير
جريده الاهرام خبير الشؤون الفلسطينيه
وابدا من رام الله مع محمد الحوراني سيدي
محمد كيف تفهم اللقاء الذي جرى بين الرئيس
السيسي وعباس بعد اربعه ايام فقط من لقاء
السيسي بدحلان
ا في الواقع مصر تتعايش مع تهديدات خطيره
تمس امنها القومي ان كان في الاراضي
المصريه او تحديدا في سيناء ونحن نتفهم
بصراحه ان المصريين يمكنهم ان يروا من
يحبوا ومن لا يحبوا لتناول مواضيع تتعلق
بالفعل بامرهم القومي خصوصا وان هناك جنود
وشرطه ومواطنين يقتلون كل يوم في مصر
واعتقادنا انه من الطبيعي ان ترى مصر كل
ما من شانه ان يخفف او يدحر هذه الموجه مع
فهمنا بالتوازي ان علاقات السلطه
الفلسطينيه ومنظمه تحرير مع الدوله
المصريه كدوله عريقه هي علاقات ثابته
وواضحه وقائمه على التفاهم المتبادل لذلك
اي اليوم لقاء السيد الرئيس مع الرئيس
السيسي وتناوله مجموعه من المواضيع
كالعاده بينا وبين مصر الدوله ذات الثقل
هو انا برايي ياتي في سياق طبيعي ان كان
الان وان كان في واللقاء مع
دحلان قلت ان مصر تعيش ظروف
استثنائيه ترى وتقابل من تحب ومن لا تحب
ولكن نحن نميز ان العلاقات الرسميه هي
قائمه عمليا بين قياده الشعب الفلسطيني
طيب ما الذي يمكن ان
يقدمه ما الذي يمكن ان يقدمه محمد دحلان
في القضايا التي اعلن بانه قد بحثت بين
الجانبين يعني ما هو دور دحلان في هذه
القضايا والله لدحلان ان يجيب على ذك ولكن
بصراحه يعني انا اعتقد
انه محمد
دحلان طوال الوقت ان كان في عهد الرئيس
الراحل ياسر عرفات وان كان الان كان عامل
قسمه بصراحه وعليه ان يفكر هل يستمر هذا
الامر في ظل وضع فلسطيني يعيش كل هذه
التهديدات
هل مثل هذه الاشارات ليس فقط فيما يتعلق
ب اللقاء الذي قيل انه جرى في مصر
انما حتى بالنسبه للتسريبات لقاءات شخصيات
اسرائيليه وغيرها حسب ما تسرب وكالات
الانباء هل هذا يفيد وحده الموقف
الفلسطيني فوق ما علىيه الين تدات خطير
نعم دعني اسال السيد صلاح ابو ختله سيد
صلاح باي صفه برايك محمد دحلان يناقش مع
الرئيس السيسي قضايا لها علاقه
بغزه كموضوع معبر معبر رفح قضايا يعني
منوطه بالسلطه الرسميه
الفلسطينيه يعني حقيقه الاوضاع في قطاع
غزه لا تصر عدو ولا صديق هناك الف ما
يقارب مليون و800 نسمه عشون في ظل ظروف
ماساويه كون انه محمد دحلان يتطرق الى هذا
الامر بلقاء مع السيد الرئيس محمد السيسي
ف هذا يحسب لمحمد
دحلان التعاطي مع هذا الامر وكانه ضد
الرئيس ابو مازن انا اعتقد انه هذا
استخفاف بمعاناه الناس ولماذا لا نراكم
كافه الجهود التي يجب ان تصب في صالح
الشعب الفلسطيني وفي حل معاناه الشعب
الفلسطيني محمد دحلان ليس نكره هو احد
اعضاء الشعب الفلسطيني عضو مجلس تشريعي
فاز باعلى الاصوات في محافظته وكان وفاز
في في المؤتمر السادس باصوات كافه
الفتحاويين كعضو للجنه المركزيه في ظل
ظروف كانت تحاول قتله معنويا وس سياسيا
للاسف الشديد تصغير هذا الامر الى هذا
الحد من قبل البعض كون انه محمد دحلان
ناقش اوضاع قطاع غزه مع الرئيس محمد
السيسي وهذه ليست بالمناسبه هذه ليست اول
مره يقابل الرئيس السيسي قابله في كل
زياره يقابله وقابله حتى قبل وصوله الى
سده الرئاسه ولكن كون انه محمد دحلان
يتطرق لاول مره الى اوضاع الشعب الفلسطيني
في قطاع غزه في ظل هذه الظروف الماساويه
التي يعيشها الجميع والتي يعلمها الاخ
محمد وخلافه وغيره يجب ان تحسب هذه امور
لماذا يعني هذا السؤال يجب ان يتمحور
لماذا هذا الجدل حول يخلف على اي حد عف
اريد انا ان اسالك هذا السؤال يعني ماذا
يمكن ان يقدمه محمد دحلان في هذه
القضايا موضع البحث الان في غزه يعني ماذا
يمكن ان يقدم لمعبر رفح ماذا يمكن ان يقدم
لقضايا الاعمار ما هو تاثيره الان في داخل
قطاع غزه حتى يكون بهذا المستوى من
اللقاءات
الرفيعه يعني محمد دحلان ليس غريبا عن
قطاع غزه هو قائد وطني معروف لدى كافه
شرائح الشعب الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه وله
حضور واثبت حضوره كافه انتخابات المناطق
الداخليه في حركه فتح في ظل هذه الظروف
التي يستخدمها البعض من ترهيب لكافه
الكوادر الى انه كافه الانتخابات افرزت
اناس مقربين
على المحمد دحلان حضوره واضح وجلي وتبلور
في
كافه النشاطات التي تمت في قطاع غزه وهذا
لا يستطيع احد انكاره وم ينكر ذلك هو كمن
يدفن راسه في النعام كالنعام في في الرمال
ولكن الاهم في الامر انه
اي محمد دحلان استثمر علاقته بالرئيس
السيسي باتجاه انه باتجاه كافه يعني حل
جوهري اللي مشاكل قطاع غزه
ومعاناه البعض هناك مليون و800 نسمه في
قطاع غزه ع موجودين في سجن مغلق وفي هناك
حالات حرجه ومرضى وطلاب لا يستطيعون
الخروج ولا السفر هذه الامور كون محمد
دحلان يتطرق اليها مع الرئيس السيسي
ويستثمر علاقته لمحاوله بلوره حل بهذا
الاتجاه يجب ان يشكر عليها محمد دحلان
ويخلف على كل واحد بحاول انه يحل مشاكل
قطاع غزه في هذا الظرف الماساوي وتحديدا
في هذ الرو سيد اشرف ابو الهول القياده
المصريه في اي موقع هنا تضع محمد دحلان
وتناقش معه هذه القضايا الهامه بالنسبه
لقطاع غزه والشعب الفلسطيني
عموما يعني مع خالص تحياتي ولك ولضيفك لكن
القياده المصريه موقفها واضح تماما
القياده المصريه لا تتعامل الا مع القياده
الرسميه للشعب الفلسطيني القياده المصريه
تتعامل مباشره مع الرئيس ابو مازن ومع
السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
والفصائل المندرجه تحت السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه وتتعامل ايضا يعني وبشكل اخر
بشكل مختلف طبقا للامر الواقع ومن خلال
فقط الاجهزه الامنيه مع سلطه حماس في اما
يعني ما يقال عن ان القيادي الفلسطيني
محمد بحلام جاء الى القاهره والتقى مع
الرئيس
السيسي واجتمع معه لمده ساعتين ناقش فيها
الامور في جزه حتى الان هناك يعني نفي هذا
الكلام و يعني يقال انه لا اساس له من
الصحه وان اي اجتماع تم بينهما تم بينهما
منذ فتره طويله ومنذ تولي الرئيس السيسي
رسميا الرئاسه لم يلتقي او يستقبل السيد
محمد بحلان هل هناك نفي رسمي ببيان رسمي
في هذا السياق لا السلطه المصريه لا تخرج
بيان رسمي لانه يعني ما جاء ل يات على
لسان سلطه او مسؤول او دوله وانما جاء على
لسان احد المقربين من السيد محمد بحلان
وهو ليس شخصيه رسميه ولا يؤثر كثيرا كلامه
في السلطه المصريه لكن هذا الكلام جا
عندما يعني تو سؤالها عن حقيقه هذا الكلام
فكان واضحا ودليه ان مثل هذا الكلام لم
يحدث ولم يحدث اي لقاء على تعامل مع الشعب
الفلسطيني الا من خلال التعامل الرسمي مع
المسؤولين الرسميين ومع الرئيس ابو مازل
والسلطه ام لكن يعني ضيفين من رام الله
ومن غزه لم يشككوا ابدا في حصول هذا
اللقاء لكن اريد ان اسالك سيد ابو الهول
عن معلومات تم تداولها في في مجال السماح
لمحمد دحلان بادخال اموال الى قطاع غزه
للتاثير في الواقع القائم حاليا في القطاع
لمصلحته ما رايك في ذلك ي يعني الاموال
التي تدخل في العاده تدخل تهريب وتدخل
تحويلات الافراد وهي تدخل بشكل يعني طبيعي
وتلقائي في ظل محاولت تخفيف الحصار عن غزه
و يعني دخول الاموال الى غزه لم يتوقف في
اي مرحله من المراحل سواء من دحلان او
غيره عندما يخرج من غزه مجموعه من الشباب
او النشطاء ليذهبوا الى الخارج ويعود منهم
محمل بمبلغ من المال لن يقال له اين انت
ذاهب هذه اموال وهو حر فيها وبالتالي يعني
كل ما يقال عن انه تم السماح ل بدخول
اموال من بحلان الى غزه يعني هذا امر يخصه
وله ان يصرف ما ان ينفق ما يشاء في غزه
تحت اي مسمى من
المسميات ابقى معي سيد ابو الهول و ضيفي
ايضا من رام الله ومن غزه مشاهدينا فاصل
قصير نتابع بعده هذا النقاش
حول اللقاءات التي عقدها الرئيس المصري
السيسي مع كل من محمود عباس ومحمد دحل
ابقوا
معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش ابعاد ودلالات لقاء الرئيس
المصري بنظيره الفلسطيني بعد ايام قليله
من لقاء جمع السيسي بدحلان وعوده الى محمد
الحوراني في رام الله سيد محمد هل يمكن ان
تكون هذه اللقاءات مقدمه لتحقيق المصالحه
المعروف ان هناك مسعى مصري للمصالحه
بين قياده فتح والقياديه المف صول منها
محمد
دحلان شوف انا اعتقد ان هذا الامر يحمل
اكبر كثير مما يحتمل كل شهر او شهرين يقال
ان هناك جهود لا اعرف من اي نوع للمصالحه
بين الرجلين اولا الرئيس ابو مازن هو رئيس
الشعب الفلسطيني ولا يجوز بصراحه وضع اي
شخصيه بموازاه في سياق خلافي انه نحن شعب
متحضر يحترم رئيسه ويحترم الشرعيات ان
اختلف او التقى معها حتى
هذا واحد اثنين انا الامر هنا لا يتعلق
بالرئيس محمود عباس فقط لان هناك من يحاول
ان يض يضفي طابعا شخصيا على العمر هناك
قرارات في مؤسسات الحركه اتخذت بحق السيد
محمد دحلان وانا اعتقد ان هذه القرارات لم
تقم من دون اساس انما كان لها اساس دفعت
اللجنه المركزيه بمصادقة
بالحركه وكثير من قيادات الحركه وكوادرها
الان وهم ينظرون الى التقارب المفتعل الذي
يقوم بصراحه بشكل انتهازي بين حماس وبين
الدحلان م في في سياق القسمه وليس في سياق
نحن نريد الوحده مع حماس ونريد ان يلتهم
شمل الفلسطينيين ولكن نرى مؤشرات بصراحه
غير مريحه فوق ما في للشعب الفلسطيني
بصراحه من معانات تحديدا في قطا الريح
لانك تقول بصراحه هل هناك خشيه حقيقيه لدى
السلطه لدى ابو مازن تحديدا من تسويق محمد
دحلان في الساحه الفلسطينيه لكي يكون
بديلا عنه في المستقبل وربما المستقبل
القريب يا سيدي الشعب الفلسطيني شعب حي
عنده قوى حيه عنده قوى وطنيه وقوى مختلفه
عمرها عقود من الزمن لا يمكن ان يركب على
هذا الشعب رئيس او زعيم الا بارادته وعبر
صناديق الانتخاب الزعيم ياسر عرفات مفجر
الثوره كرست شرعيته بجانب شرعيته الثوريه
كرئيس للفلسطينيين بانتخابات وكذلك الرئيس
ابو مازن لذلك انا اعتقد ان هذا وهم
وبصراحه لا لا يوجد تخوف بالمناسبه واهم
اي طرف اذا كان يعتقد انه يستطيع ان يفرض
على الشعب الفلسطيني اي مسؤول ا سيد ابو
ختله موضوع المصالحه
هل موضوع الان في حسبان السيد محمد دحلان
ويسعى اليه للعوده الى حركه فتح والعمل من
الداخل لمزيد من المناصب القياديه
العليا يعني حقيقه رد على الاخ محمد الاخ
محمد الحراني يدرك ويعرف حقيقه ما
الخلفيات التي تم على اساسها فصل الاخ
محمد دحلان من اللجنه المركزيه وفي حركه
فتحه ولكن ما علينا في في هذا الامر الان
اوضاع حركه فتح حقيقه لا تصر لا عدو ولا
صديق هناك حاله شرذمه
وهناك حاله في داخل الحركه تتطلب من
الجميع التكاتف في سبيل وحده الحركه
واعاده مركزه القوه في داخلها حركه فتح
بحضورها الجماهير يجب ان تكون قويه في
كافه المحافل كما عدناها وهذا يتطلب من
الجميع
الوحده
باتجاه بلوره اطار من المصالحه الداخليه
في حركه ف وهذا يتطلب من الرئيس ابو مازن
بصفته رئيس الحركه والقائد الفعلي للحركه
ان يعمل جاهدا في محاوله المصالحه
الداخليه وصولا الى المؤتمر السابع بحاله
فتحو وحدويه تعيد الى حركه
فتح حضورها و لكن كان واضح السيد محمد
الحوراني عفوا كان واضح السيد محمد حوراني
عندما قال بانه محمد دحلان لم يكن يوما
الا عامل قسمه داخل الصف
الفلسطيني لا لا لا الاخ محمد الحوراني
يدرك ويعرف تماما دور محمد دحلان قبل وجود
السلطه الفلسطينيه من ايام حركه الشبيبه
من بعد سنه 82 ومحمد الحراني يعرف هذا
الامر جيدا دحلان كان مقرب من الشهيد ياسر
عرفات وكان له حضوره في كافه المحامل وعلى
مدار سنوات وجوده في الحركه وحتى هذه
اللحظه وحتى البحث عن حلول لمعاناه شبنا
في قطاع غزه هو يدرك هو يثبت ان محمد
دحلان دوما رم ز لوحده هذا الشعب وهو رمز
لحل كافه مشاكل الشعب الفلسطيني محمد
دحلان وف وفق ما تم باتجاهه لازالت حاله
من الشعبيه ت عفوا لازالت حاله من الشعبيه
تلتف حوله في قطاع غزه وفي الضفه الغربيه
وفي الشتات الفلسطيني وفي مخيمات لبنان وم
ينكر ذلك هو كمن يدفن راسه في النعام محمد
دحلان حصل على اعلى الاصواط في الانتخ بس
عفوا عفوا
عف
الاخ اشرف بس عفوا اريد اريد ان ار ارد
على الاخ اشرف يعني انا الاخ اشرف ابول هو
صحفي مصري مرموق كان اجدر به ان لا ينكر
وان يقول انا لا اعلم لا الاجتماع قد تم
بالرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي قبل اربعه ايام
وتم توجيهات من الاخ من السيد الرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي للمخابرات العامه بوضع
اليات لمعالجه شؤون قطاع غزه وتم اعقبه
اجتماع ما بين الاخ سمير المشهراوي والاخ
رشيد ابو شباك مع المخابرات المصريه وكان
في هناك جمله من الحلول باتجاه قطاع غزه
تبدا بفتح معبر رفح واستقبال مجموعه من
رجال الاعمال الفلسطينيين من قطاع غزه في
القاهره ويعقبه اجتماع للفصائل الفلسطينيه
في قطاع غزه ولكن الحادث الارهابي الذي
اودى بحياه الضابط الشهيد الدسوقي هو من
اجل هذه الاليات لمعالجه هذه الامور
وقريبا جدا سوف تعالج هذه الامور كان
الاجدر بالاخ اشرف ابوهول ان يقول انه انه
لا علم له بذلك و لكن ان لا ينكر الرئاسه
المصريه لم تنكر هذا الاجتماع وهذا
الاجتماع تم حقيقه واستغرق اكثر من ساعتين
انا اقول اشرف استغرق هذا الاجتماع اكثر
من سع استمعت الى ما ذكره سيد صلاح اذا
كان الامر كذلك السؤال ما هو الدور المصري
الان في في الملف الفلسطيني
الداخلي يعني بدايه ارد على السيد صلاح
اقول له انت تؤكد وتجزم ان الرئيس السيسي
مستقبل السيد محمد
بحلان انا اقول لك اذا كان هذا قد حدث
بالفعل فلماذا لم ترس لم يعني لم تصدر
الرئاسه المصريه اي
بيان لم تعلن ذلك تحت اي ظرف من ظروف
ولماذا يعني نفت مصر عندما حدثت اتصالات
بها من جانب السلطه الفلسطينيه ومن جانب
مسؤولين بيسالوا عن حقيقه الامر كل القصه
والروايه جاءت عن طريق السيد سفيان ابو
زيده وعن طريق المقربين من السيد محمد
بحلان وانا شخصيا يعني اميل الى انه لم
تحدث القصه من اساسه لان
الرئيس الس سيد اشرف الخبر لم يعلن عفوا
الخبر لم يعلن رسميا لم يعلن رسميا ولم
ينفى رسميا بمعنى ان المعلومات التي تم
تداولها عفوا المعلومات التي تم تداولها
وبدقه وعلى حساسيتها لم تكن مثار نفي من
الرئاسه المصريه وايضا لم تكن مثار نفي من
قبل الجانب الفلسطيني حتى الجانب المقرب
من دحلان يؤكد حصوله والجانب المقرب من
الرئيس ابو مازن لا ينفي ابدا لا بل يتحدث
وكان اللقاء قد حصل بالفعل على كل لن ندخل
في مساله النفي والتاكيد الان انت تقول ان
الجانب المقرب من الرئيس الفلسطيني لم ينس
الجانب المقرب من الرئيس الفلسطيني نسى
السيد نامر حماد اعلن وبوضوح انه عندما تم
التواصل مع المسؤولين المصريين لفوا ان
ذلك حدث السؤال وذك لو قد حدث
لاكته وكن الوقت غير مناسب لمثل هذه سيد
اشرف اريد اريد منك جوابا على ما تقوم به
القياده المصريه الان في الملف الفلسطيني
وحدود هذا الدور وتاثيره على الساحه
الفلسطينيه التي تعيش اليوم تناقضات او
اكثر من تناقض اي في في الواقع الداخلي
الفلسطيني يعني اكثر شيء تقوم به القياده
المصريه الان ا هو يعني مسانده السلطه
الفلسطينيه في مواجهه العدوان الاسرائيلي
المتواصل اسرائيل اعلنت الحرب على الرئيس
ابو مازل والسلطه الفلسطينيه بعد اللجوء
الى مجلس الامن للحصول على الاعتراف
بالدوله الفلسطينيه ا ايضا بعد بعد ان
وافق الرئيس ابو مازن على الحصول على
عضويه المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه اسرائيل
كما نعلم اوقفت التحويلات
يعني التحويلات الماليه للفلسطينيين اوقفت
تحويل اموالهم لهم الخاصه من او الاتيه من
سي اشرف اعتذر منك فقط اريد عفوا اريد فقط
بثواني قليله سيدي الحوراني هل من تاثير
للوضع الاقليمي على الداخل الفلسطيني باخت
صار طبعا طبعا هناك تاثير الفلسطين لا
يعيشون بمعزل لا عن الاقليم ولا عن العالم
ونحن ندرك ان هناك بعدا اقليميا حتى يعني
في مواضيع كثيره و يعني نتطلع الى ان لا
يركب احد اي موجه اقليميه ليحقق لنفسه شيء
على حساب الشعب الفلسطيني لان ما في الشعب
الفلسطيني يكفيه حصار مالي وقيا
الفلسطينيه سيد ابو ثم من يركب
موجه اقليميه ليركب على ظهر الشعب
الفلسطيني
باختصار لا لا ليس صحيح ليس صحيح عن ذلك
حقيقه
اي الوضع الفلسطيني وضع مؤلم جدا والاوضاع
في قطاع غزه اوضاع ماساويه والوضع
الفلسطيني بصوره عامه هو وضع ماساوي ووضع
صعب جدا الرئيس الفلسطيني يخوض صراع
اقليمي ودولي
ولكن ما يتم حقيقه استخدام زياره محمد
دحلان بهذا الاوه في الرئيس ابو مازن هو
استحقار استحقار لمعاناه شع يجب تصب هذه
الزياره في اطار وحده
خ واشكر السيد محمد الحوراني من رام الله
والسيد اشرف ابو الهول من القاهره شكرا
للمتابعه مشاهدينا والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه